and now it's working oh yeah care of my
camera Kelly why did you choose that
name because I feel I can do anything
and also I really like that song and
then I copyrighted and told everyone I
came up with it
I chose it's grace because it's my name
but Lily night today here on voiceover
Wednesday for Alou for funsies going to
be talking and reviewing in a way Los
Angeles Lily if you don't know is
Canadian and she's visiting Los Angeles
so I thought you're the perfect person
to kind of talk about all of the good
and bad that Los Angeles has to offer a
lot of you guys wonder what it's like to
live here and we're gonna give you our
opinions on it that's do it yes yes yes
yes yes first and foremost driving I
actually love driving here everyone was
like you're gonna come you won't even
move 12 AHA's worst chocolate I feel
like Ellen really yeah I'm experienced
almost no traffic have you been on the
ten no okay
what the ten it is a highway does that
Holly way what is it interstate they say
freeway I say highway oh I don't know do
I say highway all the time
you're Canadian I'm Canadian yes hey
we're at Lily's place right now is the
wonky street it's like this wide and
it's not a one-way and there's something
called red flag days and I was told this
is when there's a higher risk of fire
apparently le just gets lit on fire of
people I love you accelerate the piezo
underneath us Canadians are very fragile
okay so I was told that I'm gonna go to
LA and I'm gonna hate the people cause
they're all superficial and they all we
care about how much you man
what you do and so far everyone's been
super nice to me oh okay I went to the
grocery store and the girl helped me
pack my groceries Wow
yeah Dennis I know how rude and the guy
operating my card because I said I had
no sense
well I'm like dad you ain't lying but
like that's really nice of you it is one
thing that la has a lot is unexpected
flirtation all the time and I'm so down
Lily that's before you start shooting
I think everyone just thinks that she's
a Bollywood celebrity and you know what
I wouldn't be surprised but you probably
get Jennifer Warnes are like in my head
all the time there is a variety of
people that that are here there's a
whole youtube community which is awesome
because you get to film collaborations
with people do their is like the
traditional acting community lot of
girls walking around wearing Lululemon
all the time a head to toe and they can
go to the gym and they have no plans I'm
going to then there's like the beautiful
gay men that really like anyone
oh yeah I went to West Hollywood
yesterday yeah a lot of confusing
feelings I sublet in an apartment in
West Hollywood for three months before
here it was just the most beautiful game
and striding about every day and I just
felt like I have to go to a gym never in
my life more want it to be a gay man
than living in WeHo I know we hope we
hope we oh yeah that's Hollywood we go
let me learn something the other thing
that happens out here is that healthy is
like a special skill and everyone wants
to have hated so much so the place I'm
renting has no microwave and for someone
who eats pizza pops for breakfast lunch
and dinner I find it very hard and
everything's organic organic salt isn't
salt already organic how does it not
intersect it's like they rustled some
leaves in it and how to protect you kind
of
I stirred I had a salad I came home and
a shower oh don't feed a salad for lunch
Oh get away from I always be coming oh
the weather in Los Angeles coming from
Toronto so when I left Toronto my front
door was frozen true story we had an ice
storm don't an ice storm is a storm of
ice that's what you would think right
because I don't know an ice storm is
either basically our entire city froze
over completely
the trees were frozen and the trees were
so heavy so they started falling on the
roads on the powerlines we lost power
so people celebrated Christmas with no
power why do you have to live there just
it's so hot that I'm wearing a tank top
even though I know my armpits are ashy
I'm still wearing the tank top girl you
earned it everyone so far I've been
trying to convince me to move to LA
that's been like the thing why are you
moving to tell this you can comment
below and let me know what you think
should I move jelly should I not should
I you should move hang out with us all
the time I don't know
yeah we are well I don't even say I
guess I'm an li person you are an ugly
person I guess so
maybe I'm wearing shorts today so that
makes me a Los Angeles race has really
nice legs by the way oh my god I totally
said it you're a California person now
because that was unexpected flirtation
oh my god no you're such a wee ho